une longue file de camions bloqués
depuis 7 heures du matin impossible pour
ces chauffeurs d'entrer ou de sortir des
entrepôts de l'enseignent casino devant
les accès à la plateforme
une cinquantaine de manifestants en
gilet jaune empêche tout passage un
changement de méthode dans une ambiance
bon enfant
c'est le symbole c'est de bloquer les
grandes entreprises les gros
distributeurs effet rush déranger
l'économie on va dire pas l'arrêté pas
l'anéantir la déranger dans leur cabine
les chauffeurs prennent leur mal en
patience avec philosophie
ben on n'a pas trop le choix de passer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
hormis là en plus on est bloqués devant
des camions puis ben faut attendre quoi
passer ensemble
après trois heures de blocage les forces
de l'ordre viennent demander aux
manifestants de libérer le passage
la consigne vient de la préfecture
devant leur refus
le groupe d'intervention entre en action
cette noire peut-être se faire des
logiques mais on trouvera un autisme
on va se donner rendez-vous à un autre
endroit et puis voilà on continuera à 10
heures les manifestants sont repoussés
et les camions libérer un par un une
intervention sans heurt les gilet jaune
sont déjà prêts à repartir sur un autre
point de blocage
un jeu du chat et de la souris qui va
durer toute la journée